العلاج بالخلايا الجذعيه يعرف ايضا بالطب
التجديدي او طب المستقبل هذا العلاج هو
عمليه استبدال او تجديد الخلايا والانسجه
والاعضاء البشريه التالفه بسبب المرض او
العمر وكذلك الاصابه اما الهدف من هذا
العلاج فهو استعاده وظائف الاعضاء
الطبيعيه باحلال الخلايا الجديده بدل
التالفه للقيام بنفس الوظيفه هذا مجال
جديد نسبيا ولا تزال ابحاثه جاريه ويمكن
ان يساعد المرضى على الشعور بالتحسن بدون
جراحه او حتى ادويه الجديد اليوم هو ان
الطب التجديدي يمكن ان يساعد في علاج
امراض مصاصيه مثل انواع معينه من السرطان
على كل حال حديثنا اليوم عن هذا العلاج في
مجال محاربه السكري تحديدا تفاصيل معنا
السكريه صراع يومي يعيشه المصابون خاصه من
النوع الاول منه هو مرض مناعي ذاتي يهاجم
فيه الجسم الخلايا المسؤوله عن انتاج
الانسولين ويعاني من السكري بشكل عام اكثر
من نصف مليار شخص حول العالم الخلايا
الجذعيه من احدث طرق علاج السكري تستخدم
في التجارب لانتاج خلايا تفرز الانسولين
ذاتيا دون الاعتماد على الحقن في مناطق
كثيره حول العالم اظهرت التجارب السريريه
ان حقن الخلايا الجذعيه قد يعالج داء
السكري من النوع الاول وان معظم المرضى
المشاركين ودعوا حقن الانسولين لضضع سنوات
الاختبارات تظهر نتائج واعده لعلاج السكري
بالخلايا الجذعيه عند البعض لكن لا يزال
الباحثون يعملون على اجابه اكثر من سؤال
منها ضبط الجرعات المثلى ومنع استهداف
الجهاز المناعي للخلايا الجديده المنتجه
للانسولين
[موسيقى]
دكتور عصام عبد العليم العالم في الخلايا
الجذعيه لمرض السكري دكتور يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك منورنا في الاستوديو ونتحدث اليوم
عن نمو شعبيه وفعاليه العلاجات بالخلايا
الجذعيه خصوصا فيما يتعلق بمرض السكري
فيما اعتبره البعض ثوره في عالم الطفل
صباح الخير شكرا على الاستضافه بالنسبه
للخلايا الجذعيه مرض السكري زي ما انتم
قلتم ده حديث جدا ومهم بس مهم جدا ان احنا
نفرق بين العلاجات اللي بنقول عليها او
اللي هي مصرح بها والعلاجات اللي مش وده
مهم جدا لانه التوعيه المرضى واهالي
المرضى الخلايا الجذعيه في خلايا جذعيه
جايه من جسمنا اللي هي او اريد احنا
موجودين بيها ودي بنقول عليها جايه من
الدهون وجايه من الدم وكخلافه وفي خلايا
جذعيه ودي لها قدرات محدوده الخلايا ديت
ما تقدرش تعالج السكري هو في في كتير جدل
انها بتعالج السكري بس علميا ده مش حقيقي
لكن الخلايا اللي هي ممكن تعالج السكري
عشان تحل محل الخلايا المصابه هي الخلايا
اللي مستخرجه من الجنين او الخلايا
بنسميها المستنسخه المستنسخه ديت يعني
دكتور عصام عشان احنا كمان نبسط للمشاهدين
كثير بالفتره الاخيره عم بتضل نسمع خلايا
جذعيه بعلاجات كذا مرض يعني للتجميل
وللفوائد الجمليات وحتى للامراض المستعصيه
ما هي الخلايا الجذعيه التي نتحدث عنها
هذه المره والتي تتعلق بالسكري اوكي كثير
من العدد بتتكلمي عنه بتسمع عنه مش صحيح
وفي قليل صحيح ما بنقدرش نقول كله مستحيل
لانه الخلايا اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها في
مرضى السكري لو اتكلمنا عن المرض السكري
بشكل خاص برضو سكري الناس لازم تفهم ان هو
مشكلته ايه هو فين النوع الاول والنوع
التاني وفي نوع تالت النوع ان هو المشكله
كلها ان الخلايا اللي بتفرز مش موجوده
فقدت بسببه او باخر يعني فالفكره انك احنا
محتاجين نعيد تكوين هذه الخلايا او او
ننقلها للمريض بحيث انها تفرز الانسولين
فيعتمد عليها من غير
ايلي فانت عايز خلايا تست او تتحول لخلايا
بتفرز الانسولين فالخلايا ديت هم نوعين
اللي يقدروا يحلوا الازمه ديت الخلايا
اللي مستغرقه من الاجنه اوكي وبنسميها
الجنانيه وفي خلايا بنسميها الخلايا
المستحثه دي اللي اكتشفت حديثا من العالم
الياباني واخد عليها جائزه نوبل ان احنا
ممكن ناخد عينك دم منك او او اي خليه
جسميه ونعملها حاجه اسمها عده برمجه نعمل
الجنين بتاعك اوكي فدي حاليا هي اللي فيها
نجاح كبير جدا وفيها كلينيكال او بنسميها
تجارب سريريه من شركتين كبار هم دول اللي
نقدر نقول يعني اقدر اقول لك ما فيش علاج
في خلايا الجذعيه للسكري دكتور حتى نبسط
للناس يعني المعروف انه الانسولين هو
هرمون تفرزه البنكرياس هل يمكن تحويل
الخلايا الجذعيه الى خلايا بن كريسيه عند
زراعتها في البنكرياس يمكن ان تفرز بشكل
طبيعي هرمون الانسولين بالضبط السكر في
الدم هو نوعين الخلايا اللي انا اتكلمت
عنهم دول قادرين على المتحوله لكن لما
بيتحولوش بعد النقل بيتحولوا قبل النقل
لازم يتنقل لازم الخليه دي تتحول في علشان
كده مش اي اماكن تقدر تعمل ده فهو اللي
احنا نقدر نعتمد عليه في في
نتائجه اعلنت واحد 2021 ده من من بوستان
ده خد اول جرعه من الخلايا الجذعيه اللي
هي اللي هي بنسميها المستنسخه وده وانتجت
الانسولين وهو عنده النوع الاول وكان له
40 سنه عنده
فده كيس مشهوره جدا وادوا له نص الجرعه
نشوف الامان بتاع الخليه ديت وفضلت فعلا
بعد ثلاث اشهر يبتدي يستغنى عن السعر اكتر
من 90% من الانسولين اللي بياخده يوميا
فده كان تطور كبير جدا في مجال الخلايا
الجذعيه بالنسبه لمرض السكري في الفتره
الاخيره في اخر سنه نفس الشركه ابتدى
نقلوا لاكثر من ثلاث من ثلاث مرضى عشان
نشوف امان مدى امان هذه الخلائق نحن نتحدث
عن حياه جديده سليمه لمرضى السكري من
النوع الاول اذا انا مريضه سكري وبدنا
النوع الاول وساستفيد من العلاج بالخلايا
الجذعيه ما هي المراحل ماذا علي ان ابدا
اولا
كل الكتير اللي بتسمعوا لازم متخصص عشان
لان انت في في كتير اعلانات ظاهرها صحيح
اوكي فلازم تقدر شخص متخصص تفهم منه قبل
ما تاخد اي خطوه وتروح تبتدي تعالج تعالج
ثانيا حتى اليوم انا عضو الجمعيه الدوليه
للخلائق الجذعيه حتى اليوم ما فيش علاج
مصرح به باستخدام الخلايا الجذعيه لمرض
السكري ولكن خلال السنوات القليله القادمه
بنتوقع ان في علاج لانه في خطوات للابروف
بتاع العلاج لانه حاليا ابتدينا بندي نص
الجرعه بخلايا معينه وبتتعمل في معامل
معينه حتى مش مش اي مكان يتعمل فيه وبعد
كده بندخل لمرحله ثانيه
وهكذا عشان تاخد الابروبه لكن كل ما بنسمع
عنه سواء في دول معينه فيها او القوانين
فيها مرونه هي اللي بتسمح ما فيش عقاب
لهذه الهيئات او المؤسسات
فبيحقن خلايا مستخرجه من جسم المريض
فمعتمد على ان الخلايا دي مش هتضر المريض
وفعلا مش هتضر بس ممكن ما تفيدوش فالسؤال
الاخير انك هناك العديد من الوسائل تقوم
بالتخفيف من مرض السكري كحقن الانسولين
ولكن لا تقضي عليه مخبريا يقال انه
الخلايا الجذعيه تقضي على السكري تماما في
الجسم هذا المرض خلال عشره ايام لاي مدى
هذا دقيق ده دقيق بشكل كبير ولكن احنا
بنرجع برضو نقول نبدا ولكن هي الفكره انه
فعلا مظبوط لان انت لما بتخن الخلايا اللي
بتفرز الانسولين الخلايا ديت بتبتدي
تتعامل مع السكر في الدم بتعمل بتنظم
السكر في الدم وبتعمل بتستجيب لنسبه السكر
في الدم يعني سكر نسبه انا اكلت اكله فيها
سكري كتير سكر كتير بتفرز كميه انس اكتر
وهكذا لان دي شبه بالظبط الخلايا اللي
موجوده كانت موجوده في جسم المريض فلو لما
بنقول العلاج ان شاء الله يكون ابروف ده
هيكون بيرمين يعني مش حاجه مؤ قته انت
محتاج تعمل
كل فترات قليله احنا مش
العالم فيها الخلايا الجذعيه لمرضى السكري
شكرا شكرا